keisha it is so wonderful to see your
face
uh i just want to say congratulations to
you first of all because you are part of
big brother all-stars and that means so
much because fans were so excited to see
your name
on the roster so what did that mean for
you to be part of it and also to walk
into the big brother house after one of
my favorite seasons season 10
12 years ago it's been a long time
it happened yeah it was amazing to walk
back into that house
i mean just to be back in the big
brother house was just
overwhelming and then to see all of
these great players and to be in there
with them
i it's so hard to describe like the
emotions
i mean it felt like a dream like
am i really doing this again
yeah and if you watch last night you'd
be the first one evicted i mean
it sucks let's just say it just sucks
that you have to play your game it does
let's just say uh but you know that
you've sat with it for a few hours now
how are you feeling about it
okay i agree with you it sucks
yeah but honestly
um you know now in my head i'm going
back through
everything yeah everything
where i messed up uh oh the mistakes
what were the mistakes what do you feel
was the initial mistake that you made
it's only been a week in the house what
was that mistake for you
um you know i needed to i needed to go
to cody
the night that he won hoh and i needed
to introduce myself
i needed to have a conversation with him
um it was just really hard to kick it
off like that
because i'm so overwhelmed you know
i'm in here with all the people and it's
just so overwhelming
and i really was a target for him i'm
like
totally not what i would have expected
yeah
let's talk about because cody you know
couldn't pick janelle couldn't pick case
or because of the whole state uh
security suite
and he had to go with you and kevin were
you surprised that he picked you
i i wasn't surprised that he picked me
after janelle
saved herself um
honestly i'm surprised that it was kevin
beside me i thought it would be
nice i really did i
i thought it would be memphis and i that
would be up on the block
so you have that conversation with cody
you're you're talking to
did you have an indication there was a
good chance that you were going to
be a victim when you had that that talk
with him
the second time that i had to talk with
him yeah
uh you know he seemed
you know whenever he was talking to me i
was like i promise you
you know you're safe like i won't i
won't come after you like i give you my
word
you know i was trying to be very genuine
and i wouldn't have
like i would have held that promise um
because that's the one thing i wanted
people to know
that i like i'm an honest player
but unfortunately you know i don't know
what was going on behind the scenes
and in my head i kept thinking oh this
is big brother
like i'm really not sure like if he can
be trusted right right
it's a game yeah and then you get 13-0
in terms of votes and seriously i
thought memphis after you got nominated
he was comforting you
i mean you should you must have expected
him to give you a vote
well the thing with memphis was it's
funny um i was having to drag
information out of him he also was like
starting to separate himself from me
you know he would like leave the room
you could tell he wasn't around me as
much as he was like the first day or two
before i went up so i could already tell
the separation was starting
and the challenge the fruit stacking
challenge
i mean enzo wins kevin's doing a great
job he doesn't look at the time with him
and his challenges
uh for you was it just fatigue was your
arms tired was there a struggle with
what happened
okay these guys most of them except for
ian they're so
tall like enzo's next to me you have to
put the tallest person next to me he's
right
banana like it's nothing like his
his feet are touching the ground and
he's just like going at it like
so easy and here i am i'm like
struggling
you know to get this banana going but
you know at the end like
day it wasn't about the banana it was
about the puzzle
but there's so much pressure like i know
at this point like if i don't win this
there's such a good chance that i'm
walking out the door so i think as i'm
starting to stack like the puzzles my
hands are
shaking like the house guests were like
you're literally shaking
yeah and how was it different for you
this time around being in the house from
the coved to
the isolation talking to julie chen
moonves the way there's no audience
did it feel very different or do you
think it was the same
no it was definitely different um you
know you
you know being out in the real world you
know everyone wears masks everyone stays
away from each other
um going into the house like it was nice
to be able just to hang out with people
to hug
them and not think twice about it you
know to sit next to them like
16 of us are hanging out like now like
does
that never happens so
yeah yeah so who do you want to win
and why i have like top
three here going on in my head as of
right now i'm sure it will change as i
continue to watch
um but you know i really like janelle i
feel like
she stood by me no matter what and she
was like i'm not turning my back on you
um you know i just didn't have the
numbers uh
second i would say caser
because i just think he is a total legit
sweetheart
and you know i would love to see
somebody like that go the whole way
um devon she's a good player
i think she deserves to go further than
what she has in her past seasons
so i would say those are probably my top
three
nice and out of the week just being
there for the week what was the best
experience for you
you know building relationships with
people um
there's a few people that i really got
close to you know for
for the viewers it's a week but for us
it seems like a month
you know we're there non-stop next to
each other
and there's some really great people in
the house
who do you not want to win
cody
or memphis i could take either
well now we know oh it's so good to talk
to you keisha and
it was so wonderful seeing you on the
show and uh
have a wonderful day thank you so much
you will get your phone back
i know thank you so much